Andrea Mitchell is about to start over
in Chapman auditorium so we'll go live
over there now for many animals I think
most of us remember him also from FPL
but now he is with Comcast and they are
the wonderful people who have dropped
the feed cable so we can be on c-span we
are really most pleased you will
recognize him immediately sparrow canton
thank you very much she really stole my
line
in my introduction but I will go on it's
my pleasure to be here to introduce Miss
Andrea Mitchell she's the author of
talking back to presidents dictators and
assorted scoundrels this Mitchell joined
NBC News in 1978 as a general
correspondent based in Washington DC in
1979 she was named NBC News's energy
correspondent in that capacity she
reported on the energy crisis and Three
Mile Island before joining nbc15 and
Philadelphia MS Mitchell is the chief
foreign affairs correspondent for NBC
News a position she's held since 1994
she reports on evolving foreign policy
issues in the United States and abroad
on all NBC news broadcasts including NBC
News Nightly News with Brian Williams
today and both CNBC and MSNBC in
addition to reporting on variety of
foreign affair issues 19 2004 I'm sorry
in 2004 Mitchell also covered the 2004
presidential campaign on MSNBC and NBC
and she's also a panelist on hardball
she's also was the first reporter to
break the story about the Democratic
presidential nominee Senator John Kerry
had chosen John Edwards as a running
mate so she can scoop as well I in 2005
miss Mitchell received the prestigious
Goldsmith career award for excellence in
journalism from the John F Kennedy
School of Government and in 2004 the
radio television news Directors
Association honored miss Mitchell with
the Leonard Zelig Award for contribution
to the protection of First Amendment
freedoms and of course in September of
this year the specials first book
talking back a memoir about her
experiences as one of the first women to
cover five presidents Congress and
forest policy was published the core
everybody knows that she is the wife of
Alan Greenspan just give you a few ideas
of how people are looking at our book
Tim Russert said Andrea Mitchell is
smart feisty and irreverent and so is
this book Andrea Mitchell has always
been our first reporter to go on to
report with big stories of breaking in
Washington or throughout the world this
is her behind the scenes story of what
it's like to be the first out of the
door middle of history
year after year it's an entertaining and
instructive trip throughout time and
that's from Tom Brokaw and Jim Lehrer
says talking back is an adventure book
about the life and times of a premier
American reporter she's also a handbook
on how to craft a journalism at the
highest most pressurized and visible
level Andrea Mitchell is among the very
best in the business
her book is about why ladies and
gentleman please help me welcome to the
stage the author of talking back to
presidents dictators and assorted
scoundrels NBC foreign affairs
correspondent Andrea Mitchell
thank you
thank you all it is I can't tell you how
wonderful it is to be here this is the
most extraordinary and I've traveled all
over the country what's talking back but
it is wonderful to be here in Miami and
to have been invited to the Book Fair
and to be among you and among so many
wonderful authors this is a tough time
to be a reporter in Washington look it's
a tough time to be a politician in
Washington I think and I try to talk I
write about it and talking back about
how our profession has changed how cable
24/7 and the internet have changed what
we do and also of course the events of
the past five years the events leading
up to 9/11 the pre-war intelligence how
we in the media got it wrong along with
everyone else who got it wrong and I got
to tell you things have become so nasty
in Washington these days it's really
nice to be in Miami those of you who
watch c-span on Friday night might have
been watching the debate over the
withdrawal from Iraq resolution which
was what I called a sign field debate
this was truly a debate over nothing a
debate over everything and a debate over
nothing at the same time because if you
saw the vote more than 400 Congress
members voted against a withdrawal
resolution when in fact at least half of
them believe that some kind of
withdrawal ought to be voted and it was
an attempt by the Republicans to
embarrass the Democrats and all over
this fight
that some of you may have seen on this
morning's talk shows involved Jon
Martha's suggestion that there be a
withdrawal in all deliberate time and
the Republicans then counter attacking
and saying okay if you want to withdraw
let's have an immediate withdrawal which
is not what John Murtha said and not
certainly what the Democratic leadership
wanted and before we knew it we had
people suggesting that this 37 year
Murray
veteran from a working-class district in
Pennsylvania Johnstown Pennsylvania was
somehow similar to a coward and was
somehow analogous to anti-war activists
which he is not he is a major defender
of the military so it was it was just
one of those cases where it was the
Friday night before Thanksgiving holiday
they were all supposed to be voting on
taxes and budget appropriations and
instead they got themselves wound up in
knots over this the president this
weekend in Beijing and Korea tried to
sort of dial it back a little realizing
that taking on an icon with the military
is not exactly the best posture for the
White House but at the same time the
Republican National Committee is running
new ads today in Nevada against Harry
Reid trying to dial it back up again so
we are off to the races and it is a year
before the midterm elections and the
atmosphere in Washington is about as
ugly as I have ever seen it and I've
been in Washington since 1976 so and
before that as I write in talking back
was a local reporter in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania so in the book I tried to
anticipate these debates and to write
about how we got to this ugly past you
know I came to Washington and people in
both parties worked with each other and
there were senators some from Florida a
lot and child´s and others who worked
very closely with Republicans when there
were moments where there should be
bipartisan approaches to tough problems
you heard about my husband Alan
Greenspan well he in 1983 when I first
knew of him was an economist working on
Wall Street who had come to Washington
to help out with Tip O'Neill and the
leaders of the Democratic Party the
leaders of the Republican Party the late
Senator John Heinz and the late great
Daniel Patrick Moynihan and they were
all trying to craft a Social Security
compromised with least stabilized the
social
purity system for the next couple of
decades until a more permanent fix could
be worked out well who knew that the
so-called permanent fix would never be
worked out still hasn't been that nobody
has addressed Medicare which is the
biggest gaping hole in our budget
forecast no one has taken a look at any
of the serious issues that we have to
deal with everyone right now is
distracted by minor issues and by of
course the overwhelming tragedy that is
now taking place in Iraq Don Rumsfeld
was on some of the talk shows and my
good friend Bob Schieffer was
interviewing him this morning on Face
the Nation and was very optimistic about
what is going to happen after this boat
and how the Iraqis are going to begin
standing up their own forces and how
Americans are going to begin to be
withdrawn on some sort of a timetable as
the Iraqi political situation begins to
coalesce which we all hope it will but
in the interim what we are seeing is in
all the polling a great deal of concern
and emotion across America about the war
how it's been prosecuted how many many
American families have suffered through
loss of kin in Iraq
how many Iraqis have suffered who have
been so brave at trying to stand up to
this insurgency this group of terrorists
so we have major problems as a country
and I think all of us hunger for
Washington to deal with it and for the
news media to bring you as straight
forward an account of possible and to
hold people to account so when talking
back I try to trace back how did we get
to this place and there was you know in
my own career in journalism I recovered
energy in the first energy crisis when
Jimmy Carter was president and had just
come to Washington a couple of years
earlier I was recruited by a local
station in Maryland in the Washington to
cover Maryland because they figured that
anyone who had covered
the Philadelphia big Democratic machine
led by a very controversial very
colorful man named Frank Rizzo had
learned enough about corrupt politics to
cover Maryland so I was off to the races
almost literally because one of the big
issues was a federal court case
involving the bribery and mail fraud
conviction ultimately conviction was
later overturned but the trial on
charges of the governor of Maryland and
it involved who had tried to sell a
racetrack with some illegal action
supposedly in the interim well it was
very colorful and I was thrown right
into this and eventually the network
noticed me and hired me to be general
assignment and I said well no one's
covering energy there are gas lines and
so I wall adhered for energy and the
next thing I knew Three Mile Island
happened so I I write about how I ended
up becoming an unlikely expert on
nuclear power and for the first week of
that crisis nobody sent me I was in the
Washington bureau as the energy
correspondent covering it from the
standpoint of the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission and by the end of the first
week the bureau chief was sending
correspondents in every 24 hours because
no one knew how much low-level radiation
was out there and they didn't want to
expose any one person to too much it
hadn't been measured so all the guys
were going and I wasn't sent which is
another theme of the book the role of a
woman in this business at a time when I
first became a reporter in Philadelphia
and I was told and tried to get this job
right out of college and I was told
there is no room for broads in
broadcasting
and that's the way it was and so I
volunteered to get an entry-level job
even though I'd been hired in a
management training program an
entry-level job in the newsroom as a
copyboy which is the first chapter of
talking back and it involved the
midnight to 8:00 shift all my friends
were in graduate school or law school or
medical school and I was working for $50
a week trying to rip wire copy run
coffee to the anchormen and exist in
this tumultuous atmosphere it was the
60s and there were demonstrations we
were in the middle of the civil rights
movement we're in the middle of the
anti-war movement Martin Luther King was
assassinated and Bobby Kennedy was
assassinated our cities were erupting
there was a lot to cover and it was a
fascinating time to be a reporter so
having learned as much as I could in
Philadelphia I was recruited to come to
Washington as a local reporter for the
CBS station and there I was covering the
federal bribery trial of the governor of
Maryland and eventually was hired by the
network and what then ensued has been a
fascinating fortunate a number of
experiences covering first Jimmy Carter
I was the most junior correspondent
recruited to help out on holidays and
weekends
covering President Carter and that meant
going to Plains Georgia for Thanksgiving
and Christmas well I don't know how many
of you have been to Plains may I suggest
that not even Rosalyn Carter wants to
spend Christmas in flight no that's
probably not true but it's it is a small
town so small that the nearest BEST
WESTERN where we stayed was in a town
called America's up the road so we
basically would go and accompany the
President of the United States when he
went to his mother's house miss
Lillian's house at 5:30 in the morning
on Christmas morning to begin opening
their presents and then go to Miz Ali's
house the mother-in-law Rosalyn's mom
when they had opened their presents
there and
it was shall we say not the greatest
assignment a correspondent ever had but
they were some side benefits we got to
go to Sunday school and I was the pool
reporter often covering what the
president the United States would preach
on Sunday mornings as a pool reporter
you then communicate that to all of your
colleagues and so I worked my way up in
television and eventually after covering
energy Three Mile Island happened and so
five days into that assignment I
realized as I say that no when it sent
me so I walked into the bureau chief's
office and said you know it just
occurred to me that I've been waiting
and waiting to go to Three Mile Island
I'm in charge of the coverage and you
haven't sent me you've sent all the guys
and he said in his most fatherly way
well you're of childbearing age and I
didn't want to risk sending you into
that zone and I found myself saying to
my boss well has it occurred to you that
mens are as vulnerable to radiation as
women's ovaries and I was on a plane the
next morning so there are times when you
have to kind of fight your way to get
the assignment and I was fortunate
enough a fascinating story we were there
more than a year really before it was
all over and we had assess the damage
and the psychological damage you know a
nuclear power plant has not been
licensed since Three Mile Island because
the insurance industry the economics of
it have just not worked and it's it's
remarkable given all of the ups and
downs of energy policy and how reliant
we are on the Persian Gulf that they
have not figured out a way either
through the evacuation plans that have
to be on file with the Nuclear
Regulatory Commission before anything
can be licensed or the insurance and
economic calculations that the nuclear
industry has to have before they're
going to go through the expense of
starting a new plant but not a single
power plant has been licensed since so
it has energy policy has we've seen over
the years become a major part of our
foreign policy as well which brings me
to the middle
and all the other exciting things I've
covered Camp David under Carter as well
and I write about standing on the roof
of the hay-adams hotel next to John
Chancellor as a new correspondent at NBC
watching the peace chord be signed and
thinking that everything was going to be
possible between Bagan and Sadat this
was the opening of a new era well as you
know the signing was in March of 1979
and look how many people have died on
both sides since then so talking back
also traces the trajectory of these
broad themes and foreign policy and it
is a history book in the sense that I
covered Ronald Reagan and I write about
the the problems that I had as a
correspondent I wanted to be as open as
possible about the trajectory of my own
career to acknowledge that it isn't a
straight shot there was the day that
John Hinckley was being transferred from
his holding cell to the federal
courthouse for his arraignment in 1981
and I was told nobody's going to come to
you don't worry about it you won't be
able to see anything but we're going to
send you down there with a camera with a
telephoto lens and the cameraman will be
able to capture this first sight of John
Hinckley as he gets off a helicopter
across the way and under guard gets into
a car and it'll be just 30 seconds on
the Today Show don't worry about a thing
and of course the cameraman and I were
there down near the tidal basin in
Washington and he was looking across the
way and I'm saying what do you see I
couldn't see a thing and through his
lens the same lens we use for space
shots he could see the small figure and
in my ear all of a sudden I hear Tom
Brokaw come to me and say an Andrea
Mitchell is down there what do you see
Oh of the oddest answer is I can't see a
babe but of course poor Tom didn't know
I didn't have the wit to ad-lib so I
basically stumbled my way through that
live shot and the president of NBC News
at the time watching from home said it
was the worst single thing he had ever
seen on the network so the following
Monday I came to work and I wasn't on
the assignment sheet and I went into the
business office and I said for some
reason I'm not on the assignment sheet
and I've been at the network for three
years I was the celebrated energy
correspondent and they said Oh didn't
you know you've been transferred to
radio and it didn't sound like a career
promotion at the time I love radio I
still do a lot of radio but it wasn't a
great moment so I went in and got some
advice from Roger Mudd was one of our
anchor men and he said just take
anything they throw at you you'll work
your way back in and they offered me the
job of radio reporter at the White House
covering Ronald Reagan and then he of
course just been recovering from the
assassination attack and week weekday
television so weeknight television so
seven days a week basically was the job
and I jumped into it and as I write in
talking back I was so fortunate that
against every caricature or stereotype
of our profession I was blessed with
mentors John Palmer and Judy Woodruff
the to NBC correspondents of the day the
two senior people found every
conceivable way to help me to push me to
give ideas to produce you're as well
Andrea can do that they wanted weekends
off but they also want to give me a shot
at doing some interesting stories and
proving that I could work my way back
and Judy
whose birthday it is today Judy remains
one of my closest friends as does John
as do their children they both ended up
getting married and having families and
Judy's daughter is my goddaughter and
these are connections that we make so
there is a life in Washington we're not
all just running around and stabbing
each other in the
although sometimes it seems that way but
there is a wonderful nexus of people Jim
layer and some of the other writers who
you know and anchor people and
journalists and frankly these days a lot
of us I can only speak for myself but I
know how some of my colleagues feel are
not happy with the way things have
progressed I write about the Reagan
years and people often ask me who was
your favorite president and there are no
favorites there were certainly favorite
moments I had tremendous adventures
covering Ronald Reagan for eight years
and traveling the world and sometimes it
feels as though the stakes were bigger
the Cold War the nuclear hair-trigger
between US and the former Soviet Union I
tried to become an expert in arms
control and loved the whole issue we
used to ask Ronald Reagan how come you
haven't met with your Soviet counterpart
you know Brezhnev had died and Andropov
died and chenko died and Reagan said
well they keep dying on me so finally in
1985 we had a summit in November with of
course Mikhail Gorbachev and it was so
fascinating it sounds a little a little
strange to being nostalgic for the Cold
War but Gorbachev and Reagan and Geneva
at that November and all of the staging
of it and one of the major figures whom
I write about involved in the Reagan
White House was Donald Regan the
Treasury Secretary who became chief of
staff swapped jobs with Jim Baker and
you know Jim Baker was exhausted from
being chief of staff after four years
and he and Don Regan arranged the swap
and went to the president and said it
was sort of a fete accompli we're going
to change jobs if you can imagine a
president in this day and age agreeing
to such a notion without having made the
decision himself and he said well if
that's what you boys want is exactly
what he said
and it turned out to be not a good
decision for him as Nancy Reagan would
be the first to a test because Jim Baker
had been a superb chief of staff and
became a superb tragic Treasury
secretary but Don Regan was not well
suited to be a staff guy he was a former
CEO from Wall Street he thought of
himself as first among equals he used to
be referred to as the prime minister
which he didn't reject and he ended up
slamming the phone down on the first
lady not a good career choice and
getting fired but in between he and I
had some difficult times he was very
very self-important he had a healthy ego
which is a great thing I guess on Wall
Street it wasn't a great thing running
the White House he didn't work well with
the hill it was a tough time and I write
about that and how it came to pass that
he almost really tried to drive me out
of the White House feet I was by then
moved up and I was the number two as the
White House correspondent and I had a
very tough time indeed so those are some
of the stories that I share in in
talking back but when you asked about
which President was the most fun to
cover Ronald Reagan was in a lot of ways
he had a second term problem little
thing called iran-contra but and we can
talk about second terms and why they are
so perilous for these presents you
wonder why do they want to run for
re-election why don't they rest on their
laurels because certainly this President
Bush has had his difficulties if you
look at the polling in the second term
but Ronald Reagan pulled back pulled
himself back up after a run contra with
the help of a wonderful man named Howard
Baker who I had covered on the hill as
majority leader and then as minority
leader as the seventh changed hands and
then had thought he in fact might even
run himself for president and got a call
one day after Nancy Reagan had worked
her way around through Bob Sprouse the
democratic
former ambassador former Democratic
national chairman and friend of the
white house of many white houses and a
great man in Washington she had talked
to Bob Strauss to talk to the president
about he had to do something about Don
Regan the Regan problem he'd gone to the
Vice President George Herbert Walker
Bush and finally he decided to pull the
plug on Don Regan unfortunately for him
he heard about it by watching CNN she's
not the nicest way to be fired one thing
about Ronald Reagan is he really hated
to confront personnel problems and so
Nancy Reagan used to be his antenna she
would spot when the problems when
someone she felt was not really serving
her husband well and so they called
Howard Baker his wife answered the phone
the late joy Baker who had come from
this long political family Everett
Dirksen was her father in Illinois and
Howard Baker himself son of a
congressman than a long line of
political people in Tennessee and she
answered the phone it was the president
United States asking for Howard Baker
and she said well mr. president he's at
the zoo with the grandchildren and
Reagan chuckled and said well Whaley
here's the zoo I have ready for him and
in fact Howard Baker took over after a
ran contra and really set that White
House back in shape with Colin Powell as
national security adviser for Stephanie
the national security adviser then can
do Burstein is the next chief of staff
so there are certainly ways to rebuild
support and a lot can happen between now
and the end of this President Bush's
term but we are at a very difficult time
of loss of confidence loss of
credibility my own sense is that a
number of things came together Katrina
the Iraq war passing you know 2,000
deaths and many many more casualties and
a sense a lack of confidence and a lack
of competence that's what we're seeing
in our polling suddenly people are
viewing this administration and rightly
or wrongly are believing that they
aren't able
handle these emergencies and the storms
which you all suffer down here had a lot
to do with it now Florida of course
handles things a lot better than a lot
of your neighbors and you've had
terrible experience in getting used to
these kinds of events but when you look
at Katrina
it was a changing moment for the country
and also for journalism let me explain
what I mean a lot of my colleagues Brian
Williams at NBC and Campbell Brown and
caulk Antonio and certainly Anderson
Cooper at CNN and Jean Meserve a
wonderful woman correspondent at CNN and
then Ted Koppel and others all saw
something unfolding in front of their
eyes
Brian was probably the first eyewitness
to it in the Superdome that first night
watching the roof coming apart and
seeing no response and when you are an
eyewitness you have an obligation as a
journalist to speak truth to power and
frankly reporters have been criticized
somewhat fairly I believe for not having
been tough and aggressive and smart
enough after 9/11 and before the war
because there was a rallying around and
there was I think I pull embackment in
moments of tragedy we were as affected
as anyone else
obviously by everything that happened to
our nation which changed our country
forever but I think there was probably
an attempt to give them the benefit of
the doubt and to be as understanding as
possible well in this situation in
Katrina we had passed that point because
we were on the ground not me personally
but my colleagues and they were seeing
that water and food had not been dropped
that the mayor of New Orleans seemed
unaware was unaware when Tim Russert
asked him ten days later how come you
didn't accept 900 passenger seats on
Amtrak on Saturday the day before the
storm to get the
most vulnerable of a qyz out and every
community is supposed to have an
evacuation plan on file with the federal
government we are told that it's one of
the benefits post 9-11 of having
homeland security of which FEMA is now a
part so that if first responders are not
performing up to speed they will be
tested and tasks in advance by the
federal government seemingly that didn't
happen there weren't enough federal
people on the ground and the local
officials did not respond adequately so
there is plenty of blame to go around
and I know it's controversial that many
of the people in the news media were
criticized for being too out there but
when Brian Williams on Thursday night
said to Michael Brown the former head of
FEMA on Nightly News live why haven't
you dropped water and food at the
convention center we have helicopters
and here you know the Coast Guard
helicopters had done enormous ly
wonderful work rescuing people from
rooftops and bringing people out but how
can you let 20% of the population be
left untouched the poorest the most
vulnerable the people who are so
dependent upon their monthly checks and
Social Security and are not going to
want to leave look at the calendar this
storm hit right before the end of the
month and that's right before their
checks were arriving the following week
they were afraid to leave they didn't
have resources and so that's when their
governments local state national have to
help them out that's why you had this
response from the journalists and I
think it did change the atmosphere of
what of the way reporters view their own
role now can it go too far yes I think
we have to be passionate we have to be
accurate we have to be substantive has
television news cable talk changed the
way we are observed and perceived by you
in the audience yes I think that 24/7
cable news talk has become merged in a
fashion with
the straight newscasts that we all do
both on cable and on broadcast and I
think that in people's minds sometimes
the opinions that are expressed the
analysis the commentary have become
confused with straight reporting and
that that has diminished us as a
professional and that we have to make we
have to be more wary of the firewalls
that should exist back in 1992 I had
covered the Clinton campaign from the
very first day and some of the more
extraordinary experiences were that sort
of rollercoaster of that particular
campaign but in 1992 Bill Clinton was
elected I was in Little Rock covering
the transition and I got a call from my
bureau chief Tim Russert and he said
I've got good news and bad I had been
covering the hill before I covered
Clinton I had been covering the bush the
first Bush transition then covered
Congress for four years which is a
chapter called scandal on the hill and
it was that and more it was some of the
most interesting for years I've ever had
as a reporter and I had gone off to
cover Bill Clinton and Russert said
you're going to be the chief White House
correspondent covering Bill Clinton but
we can no longer have you on the Today
program doing political analysis once or
twice a week because you can't have the
White House correspondent also doing
analysis because it would you know
confuse people to see you in both roles
that was 1992 which now seems as I write
quaint by standards we all are you know
as as you know I do hardball I do Chris
Matthews Sunday show and happily so I'm
on Meet the Press I'm another broadcast
and we now have a different view of
ourselves but I still always as I know
Brian and others do try to keep as much
distinction as I can between giving
analysis which I think is appropriate
without editorializing or giving
commentary and there is a distinction
and I've had all of these adventures and
it does on cable give us a great
opportunity to share
more insight yes I do don imus and
people ask me what is done I'm as like
and if you listen to him in the morning
you know what Don Imus is probably like
in fact is he's a really smart
interviewer and I've called in from
Afghanistan and Pakistan and Sudan and
other places and I get more time on Don
Imus his show in the morning to talk
about some of these big issues and I
think he does a terrific job of covering
politics and foreign policy in his own
fashion now it's not exactly what we do
on NBC Nightly News with Brian Williams
but everything has its place so I've had
this this wonderful career and I wanted
to share it and take you behind the
scenes of what it was like to meet my
husband when he first was on Wall Street
working as an economist I was covering
Reagan and I said actually to David
Gergen and some of you may know and see
on c-span and other shows and I said to
David Gerken who was working in the
Reagan White House explain to me how you
can spend more on defense cut taxes and
balance the budget because I'm not
getting this trickle-down thing and he
said well why don't you leave me alone
and talk to a real economist talk to
Alan Greenspan whom he had known in a
Ford white house and so I said who was
Alan Greenspan well I called him and he
was working in New York I was in
Washington and we started talking about
budget deficits and economics
fascinating subjects and actually I
think they are and so about a year later
neither of us wanted to move too quickly
on this we we had a day we went out for
dinner in New York and discovered that
we both love baseball and music and he
was a former jazz saxophone and clarinet
player and I was a former violinist and
we just had a great time and still we're
dating he was in New York I was in
Washington and then one day Ronald
Reagan called and offered him the job of
Federal Reserve Chairman
eighteen years ago and so we quickly had
to figure out the rules of the road I
went in to see the bureau chief and said
well clearly I'm not going to cover
monetary policy and because they say
Alan hasn't done any reporting for NBC
News and this is a system that has
worked well for 18 years and I try to
share some of our experiences and what
it's been like if you think it's easy
being a reporter being married to
someone who knows secrets who doesn't
tell secrets I can tell you haven't been
there was the night when we were at a
Christmas party and he was huddled in
the corner and I write about how he was
talking a lot of reporters there were a
lot of public officials and he was
talking to an official of they seemed
very engaged in very upbeat I was a
Saturday night and I said when we left
what was that all about and he said oh
nothing much and we've got home and we
were having the Federal Reserve
officials over and their wives the next
day for a Christmas party at our house
so I was going to set the table and get
a head start on the dinner party and so
Alan went to bed and I said well I'm
going to arrange the flowers and get
some things fixed for tomorrow night and
he didn't the dog tell me to get some
sleep that it was going to be a tough
day for me tomorrow that I didn't
realize so I got to bed around 1 o'clock
in the morning and at 5 o'clock Sunday
morning the phone rang and it was NBC
saying there's a report overseas that
Saddam Hussein has been captured and I
turned to Al and I said is this what you
guys were talking about last night and
he said don't ask me that question
so I had to jump out of bed and make
calls get it confirmed get on the
telephone get on the air we did a
network interrupt at 5:30 with Tom
Brokaw and then rushed into the office
and work all day so he hasn't exactly
been forthcoming so I'm I'm looking
forward to him stepping down as he and a
whole new career for him whatever it
just he decides to do but we've had a
wonderful experience and it has taught
me a very valuable lesson that we
shouldn't be overly cynical it's fair to
be skeptical about public officials but
I've seen another side of it I've seen
amazingly dedicated people who work for
the Federal Reserve and other people in
government as well and I know a little
bit something about what it's like to be
on both sides of the criticism and I've
tried over the years to sort of
condition my reporting with least an
acknowledgment of what it must feel like
whether the person is Hillary Clinton
the New Hampshire in the first campaign
in 92 with everything breaking about
Jennifer flowers and wheat chasing after
her and at the same time I write about
how ambivalent I felt because she was
part of the strategy she was part of the
team he was campaigning you know
buy-one-get-one-free
at the same time she was a wife she was
hurt she was new to politics really on
the national level and I got to tell you
a national campaign is a fearsome thing
if you're on the the targeting end of it
so I've tried as much as I can to write
about the human side of Washington what
it's like to live there to work there to
be married to a public official to
juggle this career what it's been like
as a woman in television and radio and I
really just hope that you read talking
back and enjoy it as much as I've
enjoyed writing it and with that I'd
love to take your questions thank you
there's a microphone there so and I'll
be happily signing books afterwards for
those of you who will come by so yes sir
my name is Edie Bosch Nick I thoroughly
enjoyed your book thank you after the
book came at you were Sudan with
Condoleezza Rice and you were mistreated
my question is twofold if you would
expand on what happened over there and
my second part of my question is you had
several multi our interviews with Fidel
Castro if you can talk about some of the
things that happened that you didn't
write about in your book about Castro
sure thank you for your question I went
to Sudan in July with Condoleezza Rice
and it was a moment of great hope three
days earlier they had just created a new
coalition government involving John
Garang the rebel leader and the leader
of Sudan and there was a sense that we
would go to Darfur focus on the refugee
camps what was happening to the women
and the children and the refugees but
the murdering was still going on and we
were going to have a photo opportunity
one of those staged events in the
president's office and some of you may
have seen a bit of this on television we
tried to get in in fact secretary Rice's
translator and a number of her people in
her official delegation didn't get in we
finally got our way into the photo
opportunity they said you can't ask
questions the American official said
there were no ground rules here they can
ask anything they want State Department
people were very supportive I asked you
know what do you have to say to the fact
that the New York Times and we have
evidence that your own militias are
still murdering raping evicting people
from their villages and the next thing I
knew these two guys who were on order of
the President grabbed me from behind
dragged me from the room and it was
quite a ruckus and embarrassing and
painful and we then went on to Darfur
and discovered by the time we had landed
that this incident had become reported
around the world because of the wire
services
and it was at risk of distracting from
the whole purpose of the mission since
that time a week later John Garang who
had been the u.s. hope for stability
there died in a helicopter crash not
under any suspicious cause as they say
but since that time the peace accord has
really been frayed and has collapsed and
so many more people have died so it is a
cause of great concern deputy secretary
Bob Zoellick has gone back again in the
last week and the u.s. is not nearly as
hopeful as we had been previously that
something can happen to try to stabilize
that situation Fidel Castro some of you
may have seen in the Miami Herald the
reporting which we have also confirmed
from the CIA
and when I say confirmed I mean I can
report to you that the CIA believes that
Fidel Castro has at least a chronic
illness Parkinson's disease the Cubans
deny it very strongly and he had a an
appearance this week in which he denied
it as well and a five and a half hour
vintage Castro speech so we don't know
what his state of physical health is
he's 79 years old every time that I've
gone to Cuba but I have not seen him in
the last couple of years he has been
very vigorous indeed the interviews with
him start in the middle of the night you
wait in a hotel for the summons from the
palace wait completely dressed and ready
to go with your camera crew and then the
call will come one absolutely
humiliating time was after after two
long long evenings that ended at 3:00 or
4:00 in the morning with Fidel Castro it
was one night when we waited up so late
and fell asleep and the palace called my
producer down there and she hung up the
phone
she basically in her sleep that yes
thank you very much and hung up the
phone so the next night when we did get
to the palace Fidel said did you enjoy
your sleep last night and we didn't know
what he was talking about but it turned
out it was that we were supposed to be
getting an interview that never happened
because we slept through it
little did we know but I mean he's a
fascinating character as all of you down
here know better than I who has changed
the course of history
I think myself that it has been terribly
useful to him for whatever reason that
the American sanctions have helped him
blame us for his failed economy they do
have social services education medical
services drugs and other supplies but
they are lacking in so many other things
that the standard of living has indeed
gone down and without you go Chavez's
help in providing cheap energy they
would be in much worse shape than
they've been in these years since the
collapse of the Soviet Union which was
his chief sponsor and help so there is
obviously a lot of focus now in
Washington on what will happen next
what kind of transition he himself had
told me that row his 74 year old brother
would be his heir and is the designated
heir hardly a spring chicken but in
charge of the military and in charge of
much of the economy and I think the most
experts believe that the transition will
be smooth if it is to row but they will
then be some sort of collective
leadership and obviously they will be
tremendous pressure not only from
Florida and the rest of the United
States but from the rest of the world
for reform and for democracy thank you
sir based on your experience in
Washington and your knowledge and in
terms as general as you wish how do you
think the current political conflict in
Washington and in Congress will play out
and more specifically do you think that
the conflict will diminish at all before
the 2006 elections I think actually that
the conflict the political conflict will
accelerate
and will be exacerbated by the midterm
elections were already beginning to see
a toughening up on both sides the
Democrats have frankly not really gotten
their message together they ran the
leadership ran in the other direction
when John Murtha made his statement in
favor of a timely withdrawal because
they don't want to be there yet either
and for those in government who debate
this whole issue you know the Democratic
presidential hopefuls in previous years
before the war in 2002 voted for the war
john kerry don edwards hillary clinton
possible future contenders all voted for
the war some might argue because they
wanted to position themselves toward the
middle of the party so you still have a
democratic party that has not found its
voice as yet either and republicans like
rick santorum in a tough re-election
fight in pennsylvania for the senate is
in fact you know running away from the
president was a hundred miles away the
other day when the president went to a
military base in pennsylvania didn't
want to be seen with the president as
much as they want the president and the
vice president to fundraise for them
they at the same time now some of them
in some of the more marginal districts
marginal Republican districts don't want
to have the president campaigning at
your side his ratings are 36 37 38 no
matter which poll you you look at and
those are not great ratings and as I
said earlier that doesn't mean to say
that events can't change and that this
can't change and that the Republican
Party still doesn't have a hold on
Congress because of redistricting and
having only 15 Senate seats for instance
at stake rather than 18 as the Democrats
do at stake but that said for the first
time in Washington you're beginning to
hear the possibility that the house or
the Senate would change hands and that
this could be a very different kind of
election if things don't stabilize in
Iraq so there's a lot to look ahead to
we had a significant resignation today
a from the Palestinian Authority the
finance minister who was one of the few
officials in the Palestinian Authority
that was well regarded by the World Bank
and by Washington and in resigning to
run for office he said within the
Palestinian Authority he said that it
was because of all of his concerns that
things were not working well so you have
elections likely in Israel and in the
Palestinian Authority in the next few
months what will the impact of that be
on the possibility of Middle East peace
there's just no good place right now in
either foreign or domestic policy to see
where the victories are going to come
for the administration unless tragically
there is some other attack on our soil
and we rally around the president as we
always would do yes ma'am miss Mitchell
I want to thank you for the perceptions
for the openness of your presentation
the amazing equality without a notes or
a piece of paper you know in front of
you yours shows the depth of your
experience my husband and I watched you
Eagle II a week after week on the
various programs I have been very
disturbed by the secrete of quality of
this administration the the constant
needs of writing the public and hide
behind threats the the escalation of
energy costs and you have been an energy
expert disturbed me gasps we just the
other day said oh look at that it's only
246 for a gallon of Jersey we can change
our potato that well this seems to be
the way this administration works you
know they say it's going to be $6 so and
it's 246 it's a terrific difference you
know in price I have been disturbed by
the lack of candor by the lack of
honesty
by the secreted reports of no you know
no reporter no anybody ever know
what happened at that famous energy
conference that Cheney conducted it's
interesting you asked for that about
that because the energy task force that
Dick Cheney convened early in the
administration which has been criticized
and challenged in court really was
modeled I have to tell you after hillary
clinton's health care task force which
also operated out of the public eye and
i think the lesson here because it
didn't work for mrs. clinton who has
since become as you probably all know a
very successful and very popular senator
in new york state
i mean she's really learned how to be a
skilled politician but i think that that
was a mistake and I think probably the
energy task force was a mistake I think
they they wanted to discuss these issues
out of the public eye because in
Washington once things are discussed in
public they become so so terribly
polarized that it's hard to get anything
done but it probably was in retrospect
not a good idea and frankly something
else we haven't discussed is the whole
CIA leak case the level of secrecy of
hiding behind anonymous sources look
we're at fault because we accept the
ground rules all too often and it
devalues the currency of sources there
are times when you need to have
anonymous sources there are times when
I'm covering national security or
intelligence where people cannot speak
on the record and where it's important
for me to be able to communicate to you
that something is happening case in
point
Danna Priest a Steam national security
correspondent for The Washington Post
did a story a week or so ago about the
secret CIA prison complexes there is no
reason why the United States citizens
should not know that these are taking
place some people would argue in defense
of the CIA that having a CIA prison in
these places to interrogate alleged
terrorists is better than turning them
over to Egyptians Syrians and other
people who have no ground rules at all I
mean we are told our government doesn't
torture well I think it's sort of like
depends on what your definition of the
as is but at the same time I think we
need to know these things
and she is now being investigated by our
own government another case of another
reporter being investigated I
acknowledge that the CIA leak Keys case
is a terrible example of the argument
for a shield a national shield law for
journalists it is the worst possible
case because the initial leak was not a
whistleblower it was arguably if you
believe the indictment somebody trying
to discredit a critic of the
administration reporters are caught in
between Bob Woodward is now the latest
who has acknowledged that he had heard
it casually during doing a book
interview didn't make much of it
didn't speak of it for two years has
acknowledged to his editors that he
should have but I think Bob Woodward's
record as a journalist is known to all
of us and is to be admired and it's just
the unfortunate way that this thing has
changed the nature of journalism and of
government service and it's just I think
it is a real tragedy because we do need
to with less frequency but still at
critical times rely on anonymous sources
in order to better serve all of you
thank you for your question I think we
have time unfortunately for one more
question sir and then I hope to see as
many of you as possible outside and we
can talk more informally yes sir thank
you the the Judy Miller episode if I've
been reading about it and understanding
it correctly which I may not have been
indicates the degree to which the
reliance on government officials may
have a tendency to diminish the
hard-hitting nature of things in general
we've gone from an Eric severide to the
general perception of news as
entertainment and the lack with the
exception of people like Brian Williams
in that engagement we
mr. Brown of hard-hitting stuff means
that we tolerate I couldn't agree with
you more
and why do we talk what is it about that
whether its economic or what the the
nature of journalism that has in effect
vitiated vitiated emasculated the
function of the press to call BS BS I
think that thank you for your question I
think that you are now seeing I think
you do see it on nightly news on the ABC
and CBS shows as well hard-hitting
reporting I just think the difference is
that there is a lot out there it does
get muddled that there are reporters on
occasion who are to captive to their
sources and I think in talking back I
write about the fact that very frankly I
was too credulous I gave too much
credibility and Trust to the people in
government who were saying that their
world WMD and it made sense the French
said so the Russian said so the UN
inspectors all fought there were weapons
of mass destruction
it was the conventional wisdom of the
time and instead of challenging it we
had no way to challenge it we weren't on
the ground we wrote the stories saying
well they allege this but at the same
time I think we the way we played it
when I went back in writing the book I
tried to analyze whether when Colin
Powell was at the United Nations we
played it up too much and in fact the
real debate was not over whether there
were weapons of mass destruction it was
whether or what to do about that should
we leave the inspectors in you know the
French position versus the American
position and that debate didn't take
place in Congress either with the
exception of Joe Biden and Dick Lugar in
the Foreign Relations Committee
there weren't Fulbright hearings on this
subject you know you didn't really get
into it because nobody really wanted a
you know lift up that rock and the
Democrats as I suggested earlier were as
reluctant as the Republicans so it is a
it is a problem that plagues all of us
but the sourcing issue is real and I
think we are all now
trying as best we can to not rely on
anonymous sources not nearly as much we
face legal jeopardy for no other reason
and realize that we have to do a better
job of covering this world for all of
you the stakes are that high our
government needs to be responsive we
need to be smarter